okay here are the questions from our
viewers wouldn't it also be eye-opening
to question of this is for you Alexander
at random people of the most affluent
areas well we could do that I could
start right here tonight question one
you go the question was maybe we'll do
that I mean we're just trying to hold a
mirror well the problem with rich people
is that they can hide right and they can
go behind in their gated communities
with their batting cages thank you and
the thing is when you well I do think
the next place we should go would be
outside Goldman's I you know what I
would think would be a fine place to do
a piece so HBO in New York where I work
is on 42nd and sixth across from Bank of
America and it would be really funny
because I'd be standing on the street
and then the security guards would come
out and say you're not allowed to be
here which is what they do everywhere I
go too but this is each bill this is
where I work this is corporate America
I'm allowed to be here by the rights of
my employee pass and so I'd be getting
kicked off my own job front I think that
would be an interesting you bet I do
the black cars pulling in and the big
rich fat bankers getting it that would
be a nice break you shouldn't have to be
that rich I mean you could just go over
to Brooklyn and interview all these
hipsters and you know ask them they're
the great reason I mean the reason why
this is great the videos you made is
that poor people don't spin they're not
liars they're not practiced in it rich
people by virtue of the fact of being
rich they lie they know how to lie they
know how to spin one one double O to one
is the zip code where more money comes
out of one double wonder below to one in
politics then the 24 lowest giving
states combined raise up the apparatus
that's where that's the east 60s between
Madison and v between 59th and 66th more
money comes for all of our politicians
of both parties from one double-o to one
than the 24 all of the human beings and
all of these 24 states that are the
lowest giving States one double-o to one
will be a good place to start good place
to live
a great place for politician I'd like to
get a place there okay why has no one in
the media explored the Mormon question
more deeply for example what does it
mean to have a bishop of the Mormon
Church and they're referring to Mitt
Romney who was a bishop become president
that's true I don't know if people
realized that Mitt Romney not only a
Mormon but he was a very high official
in the Mormon Church it would be like
you know electing a cardinal of the
Catholic Church like we've got huge debt
we've got a war to fight
I just can't prioritize the guy's
religion when I'm looking for the
president and there's other things we
ought to be concentrating true do
Santorum's primary wins despite Romney
out spending him mean money plays a
lesser role than we thought or feared
well 94% of the races in Congress are
won by the person who spends the most
money so anecdotally can you win if you
are the poorer candidate yes you can but
the odds are against it it's like 6%
yeah I mean it's like saying the Yankees
the Yankees and the Red Sox spend the
most could they come in last yeah they
could but they would don't very rarely
it'll go to one double O to one to get
that money so they get the 94 percent
it's got to go walk around a few blocks
to be fine the system is built to aid
incumbents math they've created the
system and it's it's self-fulfilling
right I mean most people it's funny when
what is the what is the approval rating
of Congress of something like 10%
America as a whole not much better
that's right and yet you'd think
something with other approvers have to
would not return most of the incumbents
but that's that's the dissonance there
is that they don't like it as a whole
but they're gonna reelect the person to
the job in their disk but it's also
gerrymandering and the lack of in
primary challengers yeah the fact of the
matter is if you have a liberal dis an
Francisco so no one if as long as
there's not a Democratic primary
challenger in San Francisco even if they
have a really low ly rated demo
kradic politician they will never elect
a Republican or Wyoming is never going
to elect a Democrat is that where you
grew up and as long as they're an cisco
just going back to stereotypes people
make these jokes about San Francisco the
San Francisco liberals they think
they're all gay you know in the chaps in
the gay parade right and I was just
there for the spring Reagan and it's all
dot-com millionaires and you're a little
bit like where all those gays I see on
TV or like that it doesn't fit the GOP
narrative of San Francisco liberal but
San Francisco isn't as liberal as you
think I know fine it's certainly not a
gay city it has a gay district like all
big cities do but the Castro district is
gave like West Hollywood here is gay
like there are parts of Greenwich
Village that are gay but it's not a gay
city you don't walk around anywhere in
San Francisco and meet just nothing but
gay people but the other stereotype then
about samus's you're looking surprised
that I'm saying Deep Ellum in Dallas no
do Center oh we didn't we read that yeah
radical I'm reading the same questions
over a good night
[Applause]